so for today's daily cancellation I'm
going to have to once again resume my
role as the dad of the internet that is
my true calling after all my vocation is
to deliver dad lectures to people on the
internet who apparently never received
any growing up so we begin with an
article in fortune.com with this
headline gen Z and Millennial worker
productivity is being crushed by Bosses
who don't understand them top Economic
University Research says now this is not
a surprising headline as we know the
favorite pastime of gen Z and
Millennials is to complain about people
not understanding them you don't
understand us is like the whiny Mantra
of our two generations combined it's the
banner we March under we're convinced
that no one in history can relate to our
struggles or understand our pain no
one's ever had it harder than us we tell
ourselves that appears to be the general
thesis of this Fortune article it
begins uh quote starting a career has
increasingly felt like a right of
passage for Gen Z and Millennial workers
struggling to adapt to the working week
and stand out to their new
bosses now let's pause and reflect just
for a moment starting a career has
increasingly felt like a right of
passage for Gen Z and Millennial workers
this is like saying eating food has
increasingly felt like a necessary step
to avoid starvation for Gen Z and
Millennials younger Generations have a
narcissistic tendency to believe that
everything they're experiencing is
somehow unprecedented and unique but now
it's really getting out of hand I mean
starting a career has been a right of
passage for every generation since the
dawn of the Industrial Age let's just
clarify that from the beginning
continuing but it looks like those
bosses aren't doing much in return to
help their young staffers adjust to
corporate life and it could be having
major effects on their company's output
research by the London School of
economics and uh protiv found that uh
friction in the workplace was causing a
worrying worrying productivity Chasm
between bosses and their employees and
it was by far the worst for jenzy and
Millennial workers the survey of nearly
1500 UK and US office workers found that
a quarter of the employees self reported
low productivity in the workplace more
than a third of genz employees reported
low productivity while 30% of
Millennials describ themselves as
unproductive employees with managers who
are more than 12 years their senior the
average uh age gap between bosses and
workers are 1.5 times as likely to
report low levels of productivity and
nearly three times as lik it to report
unsatisfied being unsatisfied in their
job Millennial and jenzy workers thought
that their abilities in active listening
time management and judgment in
decision-making needed to be honed to
improve their productivity a key
obstacle though appears to be getting
that point across to their older
managers okay let me
um let me just give a little unsolicited
career advice here if you have had
trouble communicating to your boss that
you struggle with listening time
management and decision
making that's good it's good that you
have not successfully communicated that
problem yet stop trying to communicate
it keep that to yourself and that's
because your boss is not interested in
helping you develop the basic qualities
of a functional adult if you don't have
those qualities your boss's solution
will be to fire you so if he hasn't
noticed yet that you can't function as
an adult then don't tell him like he'll
figure it out but you know sometimes in
these places it takes a while so just
just ride the wave at
least now look around your
office do you see little chairs at
little tables with glue sticks and
crayons do you see Cubbies where people
are keeping their lunch boxes do you see
an alphabet rug in the middle of the
room where you sit and listen to
Somebody read Dr Seuss books probably
not and that's because your place of
employment is not a kindergarten
classroom you are not there to learn how
to listen and pay attention you are
expected to already have those
fundamental skills and if you don't then
you are wildly unqualified for all jobs
in existence you are a broken person and
your manager cannot be expected to fix
you that's not in his job
description the article continues in
that vein and ends this way according to
research by Vitality employees under the
age of 30 were losing 60 productivity
days a year largely due to issues with
their mental health younger workers were
more likely to suffer depression to
report significant financial concerns
and to be dissatisfied with their jobs
the health insurance group found the
findings also point to a trend of
younger workers losing motivation for a
career as an increasingly unequal
economy removes their incentives to
succeed in the workplace in a viral
video responding to criticism of Jen
zers by 54-year-old comedian Rick Mercer
tick tocker Robbie Scott laid out
exactly why jenz ear might be putting in
less work than their parents did now
there's plenty to say about what I just
read but first let's watch this video
from Tik tocker Robbie Scott and this
went viral recently it has millions of
views thousands of comments from Jen
zers Millennials shouting amen uh it's
really resonated with the younger
generations and let's uh listen to it I
hate to sound like that person crapping
on a younger generation but she's
literally saying what's it like to do
something that the vast majority of
people in North America have done for
their entire lives we need to stop
expecting the same damn people who
bought a four-bedroom home in a brand
new Cadillac convertible off of a
$30,000 a year salary working at Perkins
to understand what it's like to be
working 40 plus hours a week with a
master's degree and still not being able
to afford a 400t studio apartment in bum
Iowa okay I don't care if you're a
boomer if you're Gen X if you're dead in
the ground I don't give a nobody likes
to work 40 plus hours a week no one
likes it okay if that were true we
wouldn't have so many of you trying to
become billionaires so that you can one
day pay people to do that work for you
so you don't have to do it we are not
crying we're not getting angry and whiny
and entitled because we can't work 9 to5
yes we can we do it every day which is
we're holding up our end of the deal
right we're staying in school okay we're
going to college okay we've been working
since we were 15 16 years old we've
built a huge line of credible references
doing everything that y'all told us to
do so that we can what still be living
at our parents in our late 20s
Millennials and jenzy are working more
than any other generation ever has it's
a fact we are more educated than any
other generation also a fact we are also
making considerably and
disproportionately much less than any
other generation has also a fact and
that is kind of I know people in their
mid-30s who have been working for 20
years that's like 70% of their Waking
Life they have been working and they
still cannot afford to purchase their
first home and I don't live in New York
La I live in Minnesota Minnesota that is
why some of us are crying that's why
some of us are angry because this is
this is annoying we're holding up our
end of the deal and someone on the other
side is not holding up their end and
it's annoying okay if Boomers and Gen X
had experienced what it's like to work
as much as they did and get nothing in
return they would be able to sit across
from us and go oh my God I feel you this
is so you know what some of you are
capable of cultivating empathy and I
appreciate you but those of you who have
nothing to say but judgments and calling
us entitled you cuz you don't get it
okay well Robbie I'm a millennial I'm
not that much older than you and I will
say yes you are entitled and spoiled and
lazy and you need to stop crying like a
little pathetic baby keeping your
windshields clean is always a pain
especially in the winter dirt and salt
pile up and washer fluid just can't get
the job done that's where my friends at
windshield wow come in to save the day
windshield wow is an Innovative
windshield cleaning device that uses two
magnetic cleaning paddles one on the
outside and one on the inside of your
car to clean both sides of wind Shield
all from the outside all you got to do
is push around the outside paddle and
the inside follows automatically leaving
your windshield squeaky clean we get a
lot of rain here in Nashville which
leaves you with a hazy and dirty
windshield throw one of these in the
back of your car so you can always have
a clean windshield I personally own a
windshield wow this is one of the best
products for my car whe windshield being
able to clean both the front and the
inside window at the same time is a
GameChanger I wish I had one of these
years ago the windshield wow applies
firm cleaning pressure it's super thin
to get into those tight dashboard areas
what are you waiting for go to
windshield wow use code Walsh to check
out for a special discount that's
windshield wow.com and use code Walsh
now let's just run through a few points
here Boomers were not buying Cadillac
convertibles and four-bedroom homes off
of $30,000 a year salary okay you You'
gone to Perkins in the 1980s you're not
going to find a bunch of Cadillac
convertibles that the waitresses are
driving that's a fantasy you've made up
to justify your feelings of persecution
and if you cannot afford a studio
apartment in Iowa on a 40 plus a week
job with a master's degree then then
then you need to find a new career in a
hurry I mean what's your salary negative
$20,000 a year are you getting charged
money to work your job you should
definitely be able to afford a studio
apartment in Iowa or in many other
places even in this economy like is
everybody in the world homeless if that
you can't afford 40 hours a week you
cannot afford a studio apartment that
means everyone's homeless like every
almost everyone in the world is homeless
now I guess apparently and you go to
Iowa everyone there is homeless the
entire the entire state look I know
things can be tough but there's no need
to wildly
exaggerate it's true that Boomers had an
easier time affording housing it's also
happen to be true that Boomers on
average were buying much smaller homes
and fitting more people into them these
days the average home size has gone up
while the has gone up while the average
household size has gone down so you got
fewer people who are looking for more
house okay now when I was a kid we lived
in a 2,000t single family home I had
eight people in my family sharing that
home now the average family size today
is 2.5 people and the average house size
is 2500 square feet so people want
bigger houses for fewer people they also
want to fill their houses with more
expensive stuff now that doesn't
entirely negate or explain the struggles
people have finding housing these days
not denying that but it does add a
little bit of necessary context the
Boomers were not getting jobs as waiters
at Denny's and then going out and buying
castles with draw Bridges and Moes and a
squadron of guards and shining armor
okay so just calm down a little bit with
the hyperbole are millennials and gen Z
more educated than any other generation
history as Robbie says no definitely not
not uh Robbie Millennials and Jed Z on
average have spent more time in formal
educational facilities and have earned
more fancy pieces of paper and have
spent more money acquiring them yes but
are they actually more educated to be
educated is to be knowledgeable and
there is very little evidence that young
adults today are more knowledgeable than
previous generations in fact all
evidence points to the contrary that's
because the education you acquired was
mostly useless and in many cases it made
you dumber than you were going in and if
you're mad about that you should be you
got scammed you got worked you had your
pockets picked you got I mean you got
taken for a
ride but you know I noticed these
self-pitying gen Z rants are rarely
directed at the University system which
is the system that scammed you and gave
you the worthless education that they
charge you six figures for take it up
with them why are you yelling at them
and these rants also rarely end with
what should be the obvious conclusion
that people need to stop surrendering
their money and their minds and their
financial Futures to these institutions
that will do nothing but squander and
destroy all of it now it is true that
Millennials um or rather is it
true as he says next that Millennials
and gen Z are working more than any
other
Generation Well this case that
Millennials jzy are working more than
anyone seems to rest on the belief that
baby boomers were the first generation
of humans to ever live on earth Robbie
seems to be laboring under the
impression that the human species
sprouted suddenly out of the ground like
a dandelions about 75 years ago now it's
still almost certainly wouldn't be true
that young adults today are working more
or working harder than b boers did at
the same age you know that that even
that is probably not true but at least
there you might have a case
the problem is that the baby boomers are
one generation there have been thousands
of generations of humans on the planet
did you not learn that when you getting
your master's
degree at best at
best you might have it harder
might and you might be expected to work
harder might in certain respects than
one other generation of humans one
Beyond them you have no case Robbie now
do you really think you have a more
difficult and laborious life than people
who lived in say
1910 the generation that literally built
this country with their bare hands are
you working more than them what about a
guy your age who lived in
1870 or 1720 or or the 1690s go back and
back and back Robbie would you tra trade
places with any of them do you think
you're working more working harder and
striving more to get less than any of
them
were now you can't tell me it was a long
time ago it doesn't count you just said
Millennials and JZ are working more than
any other generation ever has which
means you're claiming that you are
working more than the hundreds of human
Generations who grew up in agricultural
societies had to work hard labor from
sun up to sun up down to sun down every
day seven days a week and then come back
to a two-bedroom Cottage shared by 10
people and repeat that every day Forever
Until their bodies broke down and they
died at the age of 52 do you really
think you work more or harder than them
no not even close So when you say that
you work more than any other generation
what you mean is that you think you
might be working more than some people
in one generation might be maybe but
compared to literally the whole entire
rest of human history you are living an
absolute luxury I mean another way of
putting this is that your generation has
it easier and lives in more comfort and
luxury than all other generations of
humans that have ever lived with the
possible exception of one
that's what you're really saying but
when you phrase it like that it's kind
of hard to keep the pity train going
isn't it now does that mean that your
own struggles aren't real does that mean
that you are exper you're not
experiencing any hardships at all does
that mean that you have no legitimate
gripes no I mean you have your struggles
and your hardships and your gripes even
if your wealth and comfort basically
makes you an Egyptian pharaoh compared
to the vast majority of humans who have
ever lived still you know you have your
own hurdles some of them are relatively
significant
okay
fine it's been
acknowledged your complaints have been
officially registered I will write it on
a slip of paper and I will put it in the
cosmic suggestion box here are the
things that Robbie doesn't like about
reality right now he wishes these were
different got it noted now what because
no matter how legitimate your complaints
might be you still have to live your
life that's the thing that you people
miss the other option is to stand
paralyzed waiting for the road to smooth
out ahead of you but it never will like
you keep
saying and I hear this a lot we've held
up our end of the deal what deal what
deal do you think was made with you who
did you make this deal with okay life is
not a giant David Busters prize counter
where you just cash in your tickets and
get a little trinket from the assigned
bin well I've got this many tickets and
so I should get that that's the deal
it's not a simple exchange like that
life is toil life is work life is a
constant battle okay life is climbing
down into a pit and grabbing happiness
and success from the mud and holding on
to it with your teeth and climbing back
out of the pit covered in mud and with
calluses on your hands that's what it is
now I wish it was as simple as just
doing a few things on a checklist go to
college get a degree get a job and then
and then and then joy and fulfillment
just descends out of the cloud s right
into your
arms I wish it worked that way I really
do but it doesn't it never has it never
will if you want success you're going to
have to scratch and Claw and fight and
crawl and grab it and hold
on as everyone else has had to do there
is no other way there has never been any
other way for almost anyone except the
absolute most privileged few which you
are not and neither am I oh well now
it's okay to be disappointed or
frustrated by certain aspects of reality
but if you're waiting for someone to
come along and magically rescue you from
it or change your reality for you or fix
whatever you think is broken in your
world you'll be waiting forever and you
will die before it
happens you'll have to change it and fix
it
yourself but you're never going to do
that if you're too busy crying that it
hasn't already been
done okay that's life this is life it is
how it works welcome to it it will never
work any other way you don't like it you
don't have to like it it doesn't matter
if you like it or
not that's the part you seem to
miss and that is why you are today I'm
afraid to say canel if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed